I'm loving the style tonight aren't
those some sweet pants there's something
the thing for it you know what else I'm
living for the mini 7th Heaven reunion
that is happening tonight
I know it's it's it's been amazing uh
and it's like it's the thing in the
Zeitgeist right now people are stopping
this show again and uh it's it's amazing
what do you remember about that Cameo
literally two decades ago well it was my
first acting job ever so I didn't know
what the hell I was doing uh but they
they were so great to me and they held
my hand and I just remember thinking how
great all the other actors were and they
put me through it like they really like
put me through it but it was like it was
one of the best lessons of my life what
and two Lance Bass
said or his band
marrying the star
the star well I was hoping because uh
you know I loved Jesse from that show
and uh you know we became such good
friends after that so I was very happy
that they found each other later tonight
like fun for you as a fan to see just
Lance Beverly everyone together yes no
it's always always great to see the game
back together listen I don't know
anything more Y2K than Lance Bass and in
sync also have to say yeah you know me
and the Frosted tits we got it speaking
of Mike oh oh wait Michael is this
awkward is this awkward okay still loves
there too he was saying that y'all threw
him in the ringer it was his first
acting gig The Cameo he had no idea what
he was doing but how'd you think he did
yeah
Legendary Legendary
are we celebrating tonight well I mean
it is parents night out how are the
twins doing they're amazing they're just
cuter every freaking day now they're all
speaking and I mean every day there's a
new word
um but it's and it's harder to leave the
house now she's like
cool with us leaving the lake bye no
what do they make of y'all dressed up
ready to go or do they just unbothered
well they dressed us actually stop it
yeah they go and they pick out the
clothes I'm like all right if that's
what you want me to wear daddy will wear
it I think they did a good job they did
good
all the best wrestling
always so lovely to see you thank you so
much for your time take care
[Music]